here we are on the set of the changeling
this is Kelly Marcel showrunner and
creator of the changeling and this is
Victor LaValle author of The Changeling
novel and we're here at apartment 305
the home of Apollo and Emma are heroic
leads shall we go inside let's go
here we are in baby Brian's bedroom the
scene of the crime but before we get to
those terrible things some of my
favorite details include the curtain
that hangs here where you can see the
motif of the forest coming in so that
you constantly feel like the outside
world is creeping in and what's creeping
in with it and all of these things
become very important in season one then
one of the other really magical things
is this book to the waters in the wild
it's a good one a little children's book
my father read to me it tells a creepy
but wonderful tale that we really
appreciated it was kind of incredible
how spot on this book is when we talk
about the story of our show Absolutely
the young one is gone but they'll never
know in its place a thing without life
hard and cold
[Music]
why don't we check Apollo and Emma's
bedroom let's do it we have a few things
here as well that speak to the themes of
our show that have been planted by
Lester our production designer and it's
another place where Leicester has
brought the outside world in so you'll
see forests and boats and there's a
little Easter egg Apollo has a coat
inside that coat is a forest the woods
plays a very large part in the creeping
dread of the tail and we have more
forests over here and the fact that
Apollo Nemo are sleeping under this
painting only gains significance of
power as you get to know more and more
about what might be being suggested here
we go here into the kitchen a place of
Great Horror in all the best ways
but it's not only a place for hard times
one of the sweet details is that Emma is
a real world traveler and so some of
these magnets are from some of the
places where we imagined she had
traveled to one of the places she goes
to is Brazil she brings magic she brings
magic back that magic has huge
repercussions for everybody people don't
just disappear
tell me your life's voyage
I will tell you
Who You Are